they were once nearly extinct but over
the last two decades wolf populations in
Idaho Wyoming and Montana have grown to
nearly 3 000 thanks to a 1995
reintroduction plan carried out by
Yellowstone National Park their return
has been a giant success for the
conservation movement but a Relentless
headache for ranchers last year we
reported from Yellowstone's border where
tensions had reached a fever pitch this
morning we take you to Colorado where
some wolves have moved in on their own
and others are about to be released by
public mandate amid Hope For Less
conflict and more compromise
every morning the typically quiet and
empty grasslands west of the Colorado
Rockies are awakened by the routine
sound of Don gittleson feeding his cows
he makes a living raising cattle for
grass-fed beef and sells selectively
bred Bulls to producers so it's just you
wow 1200 acres in you when the cows go
up there yeah I'm the one that puts them
up there and I'm the one that gets
yourself
in an average year there's a lot to do
to keep the ranch running but at the end
of 2021 A new challenge was piled onto
his workload so the first time I saw the
mail he was up on the mountain that was
the first sighting when was the first
kill so that was I think about the 22nd
of December last winter seven of his
cattle were killed by wolves four of
which he received compensation for from
a government program he's Limited in
what he can do to defend his herd
because this particular pack is
protected under The Endangered Species
Act so if I catch him in here at night I
can chase them now I can't injure him so
I have chased them about three o'clock
in the morning this is the first pack to
settle into Colorado in at least 70
years scientists traced the female wolf
from Northwest Wyoming 400 miles north
of the gittleson Ranch these guys they
travel oh they travel they definitely
travel the pack caught the eye of
Colorado University wildlife biologist
Joanna Lambert who studies wolves and
coyotes across the country she's well
aware of cases like gittlesons where
wolves take down livestock instead of
natural prey yeah it's a worst case
situation A worst case scenario
absolutely ranchers who are right there
between those public lands and the
private ones or probably the ones who
are going to get hit yes absolutely but
life without wolves has its own set of
problems deer and Elk population
skyrocketed after wolves were wiped out
in the early 20th century it influences
all of the other aspects of that
biological community that are and it's
even you know has consequences for
erosion in areas if there's massive
overgrazing and coyote populations have
been cropping up in unexpect expected
places so basically while wolf numbers
were going down coyote numbers have been
going up they are in every state except
for Hawaii they are in every major
Metropolitan region of the United States
or in Manhattan research like Lambert's
showing that returning wolves helps
rebalance the ecosystem spurred a
campaign that led to Colorado voters
deciding to reintroduce them to the
state in 2020. we can take politicians
out of the picture and create a
science-based plan that safely restores
wolves to our ecosystems let's restore
the howl to Colorado the proposition
passed marking the first time a species
would be introduced by ballot a few
dozen wild wolves will be captured
likely from the Yellowstone area and
released on public land in Colorado
beginning as early as this December of
course I didn't vote for it I thought it
was a bad idea you're left to deal with
it yeah it is what it is the pack that
settled around the gittlesons ranch are
unaffiliated with the reintroduction
plan they showed up on their own but if
gittleson has one hope it's that the
wolves that are reintroduced are not
treated so preciously so if they become
a problem like here you can handle it
they can be put down
yes some scientists including Lambert
agree with gittleson to some degree so
the experimental status is sort of the
gray in a Land of black and white yeah
it renders the whole kind of experiment
which essentially reintroduction is
right it renders it more adaptive and
more of a compromise yeah and a
compromise ultimately we've all got a
kind of cooperate have conversations
about what we are and are not willing to
lose that conversation continues to grow
louder as plans to conserve all kinds of
native species pick up steam the goal is
where possible restore what we've lost
some habitats are forever lost to
urbanization but there are still
millions of Acres of protected land the
scientists see a potential as homes for
beavers bears and wolves are we
attempting to rewild the West we are
indeed at least in the areas that can
support that
and there's so many issues here one this
is highly emotional for ranchers I mean
you can talk science and data but when
they are witnessing kills of their very
precious sure I mean we saw the close-up
right there absolutely but then two you
have learned behavior and these wolves
are very smart when they learn that cows
who are less rambunctious than say elk
they know that's you know an interesting
kill and you really see how delicate the
ecosystem is here you move one little
thing and all the repercussions and the
Ripple effects it does and you know
we're trying to write a hundred years of
a mistake and that's hard to do stunning
landscape though one story a big shout
out to Kathleen secum and uh Ben
McCormick well done this